It's Mi Anne Chan!
Hi!
(applause)
Best intro I've ever received.
You deserve nothing less.
Thank you guys.
Okay, first, we're gonna talk about
the all-important SPF with you.
Now, I battle with SPF because so many broke me out.
I was like, I'd rather have dark spots than acne.
But now that I'm getting older, my skin is changing,
and I'm seeing the effect of not wearing enough SPF.
So, we're all crawling out of our holes now,
and about to actually see the sun.
The light! The light!
(laughter)
And I was wondering, Mi Anne,
if you could take us through this,
because most people like put on the wrong amount,
they don't know how to SPF,
I'm one of them.
Teach us everything you know.
A really easy hack to knowing how much to apply,
is called the two finger rule.
So Curology reports
that you could do a little, little hack,
you take your sunscreen, and you put it on...
one finger...
and then the second finger, I know it seems like a lot,
but this is how much you're supposed to be using,
for your entire face, your neck, your ears.
If you don't have hair on your head,
you need to use even more.
And take this in and you rub it in.
This is, I have to say,
gonna make me want to put this on cause it's fun.
Yeah
It really is.
It's like a new way in, I love this.
But if you have issues with reapplying sunscreen,
because it is very important to reapply,
there are a couple of ingenious products out there.
These are two from Supergoop.
This one is a setting spray.
So if you don't want to mess up your makeup,
which I love makeup, you guys know.
So I am guilty of not always be applying when I should,
you can spray it on top.
This one is a powder.
So it's a setting powder and it has SPF.
And you can just go in, touch up,
kind of kick back that shine,
and also be reapplying your sunscreen.
So it's a really great thing to have in your bag.
It's going to give you better protection,
if you would apply with the two finger rule again,
but let's be real, not everyone is doing that.
Well, also, if I'm good enough to wear SPF.
If I bring this with me,
I don't want to cream up during the day.
So this powder and this spray,
major help for me to incentivize me to actually do it
throughout the day.
All right. So you converted us to SPF, right?
But next we have some green news.
We've got the very first zero waste body wash
and it just launched this week.
Fast company reports,
The Plus body wash comes as a thin,
almost weightless little, teeny little sheet.
And when it gets wet, it foams up like soap.
And even better, the packaging is fully safe
to just wash down the drain when you're done,
because it's made of natural wood pulp and dissolvable ink.
All right.
Have you started to try any
of these waterless products like this?
I have, there are actually a really big burgeoning trend
in the industry.
This one smells amazing.
What's great about them is that,
when you're transporting a lot of product
and a lot of water in it, it is, you know
it can have a pretty big carbon footprint
a lot lighter to do things that are waterless.
It's actually an ingenious thing.
I think we're gonna see more and more of it
as we progress in the industry.
I can't wait to use one of these.
Mi Anne do you have any bar shampoo
or conditioner brands that you like out of curiosity?
Yeah. I love the one by Humankind.
Garnier is actually coming out with a new zero water soap.
They're just about to launch it.
And it's just so exciting because I have to say,
I get very emotional about this.
I am scared for us.
I feel like there isn't hope.
I feel like the big companies are just too big.
I can't do anything as an individual.
And when you see this kind of change,
you believe that we are going in the right direction,
change is possible.
These incredible innovations.
Why not?
Why are we not looking forward?
Why are we staying in the same darn place?
I just, this is amazing.
This is, and it feels like a fruit roll-up.
I'm so excited about this.
This is so great.
Well, we can't go without plucking another fresh gem
from TikTok.
Glamour reports that there's a new blush hack
making the rounds that gives your face a real facelift
and Mi Anne, I would love for you to show us how to do this
because let's face it, who doesn't want to face lift?
Honestly, blush can be used in so many different ways.
I have this one here, it's the Nectar of blush bomb
by Flower.
And you can do a lot of different things with blush.
So you can actually contour your face with it.
So I'm gonna take a little bit on a brush here.
And if you put your blush just on the Apple of the cheek,
which is a totally fine thing to do.
A little bit flush, but if you take your blush,
you can always put your finger here,
And actually lift it up the cheekbone.
And that just instantly lifts your face
without even having to use contour products right?
I'm into this Mi Anne.
I really, really, really am.
And I have to say, one side of my face
totally does look higher than the other.
Right, this one right here.
Yes!
It worked.
No it-
(applause)
Totally!
Thank You!
Than you Mi Anne!
I feel like I went from like,
Care Bear to Joan Crawford.
(laughter)
Mi Anne, you're the best.
I love you so much.
Thank you for lifting all of us up.
I do what I can.
I love you, Mi Anne.
This is so great.
I can't wait to do this with you again.
(upbeat music)